Vi faccio una domanda
per alzata di mano
sa che cosa vuole fare da grande
1 2 3 4 5 6
me ne faccio un'altra
avete mai sperimentato un pochino di
paura ansia dubbio quando vi hanno fatto
la domanda Che cosa vuoi fare da grande
Io sì
Ecco anche voi Siamo un po' di più
la passione
è la ragione del tuo prossimo passo
è uno dei tuoi mille volti
ma quando si tratta di avvicinarsi alla
passione se abbiamo delle regole
inconsce che abbiamo assimilato fin da
quando eravamo piccoli ad esempio che
alla domanda Che cosa vuoi fare da
grande si dà una sola risposta
oppure che quella risposta già la
conosciamo già dentro di noi quasi come
se tutti quanti fossimonati già avendola
dentro
funziona veramente così
quando abbiamo imparato che funziona
così
in natura
ci evolviamo per esperimenti
l'evoluzione procede attraverso una
serie di errori piccole mutazioni sia
genetiche che poi sono selezionate
attraverso la lotta per la vita in
quelle che funzionano meglio
nell'ambiente esterno
cioè noi raggiungiamo la perfezione non
nonostante tutte le interazioni
Ma grazie ad esse
quando siamo bambini non esploriamo in
modo lineare
ma in modo intuitivo
globale
i sensi ma ce ne in relazione al corpo
del bambino con l'ambiente esterno e in
cambio danno delle sensazioni che
possono essere positive o negative
quando cresciamo
dimentichiamo questo approccio
perché abbiamo paura
dell'ignoto del giudizio
sperimentare non è mai simbolo di
indecisione o debolezza
ma di un coraggio immenso
significa abbracciare tutte le
possibilità di essere abbracciare la
grandezza
tra la paura e la passione c'è sempre
l'esperimento Perché l'uomo è un
esploratore
quando cresciamo le nostre paure le
nostre passioni si evolvono con noi
Abbiamo impiegato secoli e secoli e
secoli per arrivare a trovare il fuoco
ma soltanto 70 anni per passare da
l'aereo del fratelli Wright che è il
primo mezzo che ha mai solcato il cielo
ha la missione Apollo 11 che è quello
che ci ha portato sulla luna
Ma cosa è dovuto questo cambio di
velocità
da dove arrivano queste scoperte
se mettiamo in fila tutte quante le
scoperte tutte quante i grandi
accidement dell'evoluzione umana
scopriamo che l'evoluzione non è su una
linea retta non è lineare Ma è una curva
esponenziale
esponenziale significa sempre più veloce
sempre più intenso ogni giorno il mondo
si presenta a te con qualcosa di nuovo
che cosa ne fai
rimani fermo o ti evolvi
C'è un'altra cosa che influisce sulla
nostra passione su come le esprimiamo e
dalla connessione Ci sono due tipi di
connessioni che io vi invito a
sperimentare durante il vostro percorso
La prima è quella con le persone
Ognuno ha il suo modo di sperimentarla
C'è chi lo fa dando fiducia
c'è chi la fa mettendosi vicino a una
persona che lo ispira mentore un
insegnante
però quando noi ci mettiamo vicino alle
altre persone succede una magia che un
pedagogo sovietico ha descritto come
zona di sviluppo prossimale
ed è il ponte tra quello che sappiamo
fare oggi è il nostro potenzialità
quando ci mettiamo vicino alle persone
spesso lo facciamo perché c'è qualcosa
dentro di loro che risuona in noi
noi vediamo il loro qualcosa che sta
dentro di noi ma che magari non abbiamo
ancora tutte quante le carte per poter
esprimere
il secondo tipo di connessione che io vi
invito ad esplorare è quella tra le
materie quando siamo a scuola le
impariamo in compartimenti stagni
italiano matematica musica greco latino
la vita è un fenomeno complesso Nessuna
materia sta in piedi da sola
hai fatto di scontri
di connessioni
noi dobbiamo imparare ad esplorare i
confini perché l'innovazione avviene
sempre ai bordi noi possiamo creare
qualcosa di nuovo soltanto se mischiamo
cose lontane così vicine cose che non
c'entrano niente
come società dobbiamo incoraggiare
questo tipo di esplorazione perché oggi
stiamo davanti a Sfide enormi pensate
alla transizione digitale alla
transizione energetica oppure il
cambiamento climatico
Ecco c'è ancora una cosa che voglio
dirvi però per capirla bene Vi devo
chiedere di chiudere gli occhi
pensate all'ultima volta che avete avuto
paura
che cosa è successo
che cosa avete provato Dove dove si
colloca il vostro corpo nello stomaco
nel petto
Che cos'è la che mi faceva paura
siete rimasti o siete fuggiti
Ecco adesso che Apriamo gli occhi
scopriamo che la paura è uno dei
sentimenti più potenti che può provare
l'uomo
quando abbiamo paura nel corpo si
rilascia adrenalina nella mente funziona
alla migala e prende una decisione o
scappiamo o restiamo e combattiamo
paura È la prima volta che ti metti in
gioco al massimo delle tue capacità
Io ho scoperto nel mio percorso
che la paura è una bandierina
Quando c'è la paura c'è sempre qualcosa
di interessante sotto
andare dove si ha più paura è un ottimo
modo per trovare quella che potrebbe
essere la vostra prossima passione
Ecco adesso prendiamoci un momento
esploriamoci della nostra vecchia
concezione di passione
riscriviamola ridisegnamola assieme in
quattro passaggi
1 sperimenta Dì di sì
Accogli la vita buttati
accoglie il cambiamento spesso ci
accorgiamo del cambiamento quando Già ci
siamo Spogliati dei nostri vecchi strati
e il cambiamento è già avvenuto
3 connetti
così puoi creare qualcosa di nuovo di
tuo
di personalizzato
impara ad abbracciare la paura
vi assicuro che ci puoi insegnare più di
quello che crediamo
Buon viaggio grazie
[Applauso]